[Music]
do we have like any cool new music
we'll put it in post
ah sweet all right when this comes in
there's gonna be some rad new music for
a new segment called
facts are your friends this comes from a
good
my good friend and really one of my most
important mentors in my life dr andy
young
uh he was a psychology professor of mine
but he's also um a
just someone who's helped me walk
through a lot in life and he trained me
on crisis response he's the one who let
me tag along for years with him and his
incredible team until he finally asked
me i could be on the team let me join
the team after by hassling about it
um
but one of the most common things we
would say he would say and remind us
over and over and we would go into
situations where we're doing death
notifications where we're
seeing the worst of the worst and
sitting with people who have just
experienced their lives implode
was facts of your friends facts are your
friends and so in this segment it's
gonna be a new segment that we're gonna
start doing these are simple
conversations about complex ideas
what's this diagnostic earlier on in
this show um somebody called about
oppositional defiant disorder right so
we'll have different things about
diagnostics different things about hey
in this movie it said that so it's going
to be
simple conversations about pretty
complex things all right and so today
for the first inaugural facts of your
friends
man i'm really uh i'm crushing it huh
we're gonna be talking about narcissism
narcissist that guy's a narcissist oh my
gosh she's such a narcissist my
mother-in-law is a narcissist the number
of emails kelly gets about somebody's
mother-in-law being a narcissist or
somebody's dad being a narcissist and
then most recently
is putin a narcissist the leader of
russia is he a narcissist hey does he a
narcissist is he is he
so
let's take a step back
and look at what narcissist is
and then we're gonna get to is putin a
narcissist how about that
so narcissus is one of those terms
that's thrown around all over the place
super quick to throw this label on just
about everything
jerk narcissist somebody says something
we don't like narcissists somebody calls
and is like well come on narcissist we
just throw it around throw it around
so let's step back and look at what
actually narcissistic personality
disorder actually is
it's important to know when you're
dealing with a narcissist
their life is about them not you okay so
clinically narcissistic personality
disorder means someone has an inflative
sense of importance a need for
admiration a lack of empathy a sense of
entitlement at a pathological level okay
here's some common traits exaggerated
sense of self-important
constant excessive need for admiration
fantasies of success and power and
brilliance beauty this sounds like james
monopolizing converse not really james
monopolizing conversations and inability
to recognize the feelings and needs of
others
the dsm
boy that's my favorite book
uh pervasive pattern of grandiosity a
need for admiration right believes they
are special requires excessive
admiration
my friend dr cloud henry cloud talks a
lot about narcissist
he suggests that
they have this inflated sense of
self-worth and people are always looking
to feel better and so they get a new
they they get what they want at dinner
and they need to feel better again and
then they
send the food back at the dinner table
they're not going to give me crap like
this and then they need to feel better
and so then they take it out on you and
then i'm not driving that car you drive
and it just it's this constant need to
get better and it crushes people and it
drains them and it leaves everybody
around them thinking there's something
wrong with them
it's gaslighting you end up feeling like
you're not good enough right so
at the core fundamental level a
narcissist uses manipulation and
psychological control to get what they
want they live in a world of denial and
fantasy to avoid reality
this is an emotionally stunted person
somebody who stopped developing i like
to say it's the inner seven-year-old
they spit on things they hit things they
lash out at things they fantasize about
star wars and dragons
and
you know being a rock star and having a
certain body they're stuck at
seven-year-old level like my daughter
okay
they may treat people bad but their
lives aren't about other people it's
about them they are the focus of their
world others are just fuel for that
engine okay so here's a few important
notes narcissists rarely seek help
unless something important to them is at
stake and even then it's rare also not
all people with narcissistic personality
disorder bang drums all day they're not
all loud and brash and outwardly
confident and socially charming some are
shy
hypersensitive very thin skin very
fragile and they will drag you down
underwater
gently you don't even know it until
suddenly you're gasping for air
some come in loud and
that's the one on tv right
the one that many of us deal with is the
one that's slowly under
water right
now
most people
are not narcissists most people are
jerks
or morons
are kind of an idiot
that guy
is just a jerk
or
some people have just had things
given to them for long enough that they
don't have a psychology they don't have
a operator's manual for
um y'all are coming home for
thanksgiving um y'all gonna be here at
two right because we're gonna eat at
three so you only be here by two
hey mom we're not gonna come home for
thanksgiving this year actually we're
gonna get a cabin out in the woods and
just go stay there because it's going to
be better for all of our souls
and then mom doesn't have an operator's
manual for that and so we're going to
teach her and we're going to lean into
that
all of us can be self-absorbed sometimes
all this can be selfish sometimes that's
part of being human if you're not
worried
yeah
if you're worried that you're a
narcissist you're probably not
that's one of the core core functions
if you think someone close to you as a
narcissist
pay attention to how you feel in their
presence
pay attention to how they treat you and
others
and this is um
as we get into like
the putin discussion
just stop saying narcissist
just stop with the diagnostic it's an
easier way to live
that diagnostic i believe is for
psychologists and psychiatrists and some
counselors and some family therapists
but it's overused and it's not always
helpful
it is helpful when you're teaching
somebody hey this is them doing
something to you you're being gaslight
you're allowed to set boundaries
i like to
serve people by working at what you're
talking to them not about others so
sometimes it's important to point out
what other people are doing to you and
to say like hey that's not normal that's
not okay or that guy's abusive or that
guy the diagnostic stuff i just leave
off
i just leave it off
here's why you deserve boundaries
you deserve to have your needs met you
deserve to be loved you deserve to not
be abused you deserve to
not find yourself being dragged under
water
so when people
say is putin a narcissist
i i'm not gonna give that credence i'm
not a psychologist i'm not a
psychiatrist and that diagnostic label
doesn't help anybody you get a guy that
appears to have invaded a sovereign
country and is trying to take it over
and if you can't take it over he is
going to just blow it all up
and he's going to take out women and
children and soldiers and babies and
infrastructure and
monuments all of it it's going to burn
all the ground
and so i am going to deal with that
reality i don't care what the diagnostic
is
diagnostics can be helpful but they can
also be used to blame they can also be
used to excuse
so i'm always going to look at behavior
right so going back to if you think
someone's a narcissist what do you do
how does your body feel when you're
around them do you get that feeling your
guts like
this is not gonna then don't go that's
on you to set a boundary
focus on what you can control don't
diagnose people just stop diagnosing
people focus on what you can control and
especially kill this fantasy
you can't change other people
period you can't you can change you you
can't change your co-workers you can't
change your office mate you
i guess office mates and co-workers are
the same thing you can't
you can't change any of this stuff
except for you